m
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
elle est une un troisième samedi de
mobilisation contre le passé ni terre
dans toute la france et c'était plus de
deux cent mille manifestants à battre le
pavé pour dire non à son extension à
paris quatre cortèges aujourd'hui dans
mon teint l'initiative de florian
philippot et puis dispersion tendue a
investi après un parcours émaillé de
heurts avec les forces de l'ordre au
moins trois policiers blessés
ils étaient 3000 déployés dans la
capitale
nous ferons également sur la situation
ailleurs dans le monde le variant delta
frappe fort la chine d'où est partie la
première vague n'est pas épargné on y
recense de nouveau foyer d'infection
certaines villes se recombinent l
australie sont pression également
brisbane et sous cloche dès aujourd'hui
pour trois jours
[Musique]
et puis les relations entre israël et
l'iran de nouveau sous tension en cause
l' attaque jeudi d'un pétrolier au large
doman et la mort de deux membres
d'équipage des ressortissants
romain et britannique les autorités
israéliennes pointe du doigt terran et
selon la marine américaine il s'agirait
d'une attaque de drones
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france les autorités
sont prévenus et les manifestants contre
l'extension du pass sanitaire ne lâche
rien un troisième samedi de mobilisation
dans toute la france qui ne devrait pas
s'arrêter là
ils étaient 200 mille aujourd'hui à
battre le pavé contre 160 mille la
semaine passée à paris plus de 14000
personnes se sont mobilisées selon le
ministère de l'intérieur quatre
rassemblements dans la capitale trois
mille policiers mobilisés après le
retour des manifestants sur les champs
elysées ce qu'est la semaine dernière et
elle appelle à des gilet jaune un
cortège est parti du métro villiers
direction bastille par court émaillés de
heurts avec les forces de l'ordre qui
ont fait usage de gaz lacrymogènes trois
policiers ont été blessés en fils point
avec notre reporter luc alléger après
une dispersion mouvementée qui a duré
plus d'une heure les derniers
manifestants ont quitté la place de la
bastille le défilé qui avait eu lieu
avant avaient été émaillés de heurts et
de course rapide
les manifestants qui étaient présents
certains essayé de déborder le
dispositif de forces de l'ordre
toutes ces personnes étaient là contre
l'extension du pass sanitaire une mesure
qu'il juge illégale inadmissible je vous
propose d'écouter quelques témoignages
que j'ai pu recueillir au cours de la
manifestation
il faut absolument pas que ce pass
sanitaire pas c'est de la discrimination
pure et simple et dans le pays qui se
prétend être celui des droits de l'homme
ce pas normal qu'ils aient des
restrictions pour faire la différence
entre des non vaccinés les vacciner
c'est complètement hallucinant le fait
d'instaurer un pass salutaire enfin
passer un hiver si on peut dire quoi
c'est un passe droit pour aller un peu
partout quoi un sens présent à la les
gens veulent une liberté de plus en plus
quand on en est lens demont après ce que
va être demain moi je travaillais à
l'éducation nationale et je suis très
inquiète de ce qu'on va sortir les
gamins qui seront pas vaccinés et plus
les personnels à qui on va dire au bout
de moi bah vous allez voir ailleurs
parce que vous n'êtes pas vacciné
moi je suis vacciné mais j'estime que
c'est mon choix et chacun doit avoir le
choix
il avait un très important dispositif de
forces de l'ordre pour encadrer les
cortèges qui avait était mobilisée il ya
eu plusieurs appels à manifester ici à
paris la sienne la semaine dernière il y
avait eu 161 me
manifestants répartis dans 168 cortège
selon le ministère de l'intérieur mais
ce chiffre est très contesté par ces
manifestants qui estiment que le
gouvernement cherche à minimiser
l'ampleur du mouvement
quoi qu'il en soit ces manifestants ils
ont promis de revenir dès la semaine
prochaine est de maintenir la pression
sur le gouvernement contre le pass
sanitaires et votre rassemblement partis
de montparnasse organisé entre autres
par le leader des patriotes florian
philippot est les précisions avec notre
reporter estelle hoffhart ch
après un peu plus d'une heure de marche
aux cris de liberté les manifestants se
sont rassemblés ici la place de fontenoy
a car ici une estrade a été installée et
des prises de parole ont été organisées
pendant un petit peu plus d'une heure le
cortège s'est élancé aux alentours de
14h 14h30 depuis la place du 18 juin 40
est des manifestants qui sont venus dire
non à l'extension du bassin sanitaire et
à la vaccination obligatoire pour
certaines professions à des mesures
qu'il considère tout simplement comme
liberticide je propose d'écouter ceux à
qui nous avons pu parler moi qui suis né
en 50 j'ai vu ce mai 68 j'ai vu
énormément de choses je ne pensais
jamais qu'on aurait à vivre quelque
chose d'aussi d'une restriction des
droits fondamentaux c'est inadmissible
on a pas on n'a pas ni à imposer la
vaccination surtout après avoir dit
qu'on ne poserait pas et puis on n'a pas
à voir un pass sanitaire qui sera
définie dans le temps puisque il ya eu
un amendement qui a été rejetée selon
lequel il était prévu que la fin de la
pandémie aura plus de passes et ben non
l'amendement a été rejeté donc on est
parti comme ça pour des lustres avoir un
pass sanitaire ça absolument
inadmissible pour moi grosse
mobilisation nationale contre les
décisions du gouvernement qui ressemble
à tout sauf à quelque chose de
sanitaires donc 10 2 de cohérent par
rapport à la prise en charge des
épidémies qu'ovide bas je viens
manifester mon mécontentement contre le
pass année terre donc je suis contre la
vaccination parce que je vois ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui c'est que les gens qui
sont vaccinés ils ont autant autant de
contraintes que les autres ils peuvent
attraper la maladie peuvent aussi la
transmettent donc je vois pas l'intérêt
de la vaccination
voilà pour les revendications ce
rassemblement il est à l'initiative de
florian philippot le patron des
patriotes qui revendique une 37ème
semaine de mobilisation contre le pass
est sanitaire florian philippot qui
appelle aussi au boycott des lieux où
l'extension de ce pass sera exigée a dès
le 9 août prochain je vous rappelle que
ce pass sanitaire est d'ores et déjà
obligatoire dans certains lieux de
culture et de loisirs et ce depuis le 21
juillet dernier et on l'a manifesté en
province à lyon des manifestants qui se
sont rassemblés devant l'hôpital edouard
herriot soutien est la grève illimitée
du personnel soignant tous protestent
contre l'obligation vaccinale pour les
personnels hospitaliers et contre
l'extension du passé ni tard le 9 août
prochain
sans passeport sanitaire certains
patients pourraient se voir refuser
l'accès aux soins
une aberration pour ces soignants et
côté est aujourd'hui on est un
rassemblement pour soutenir en fait nos
collègues soignants et hospitaliers qui
risquent des sanctions à partir du 15
face à l'obligation vaccinale qui est
tombée le 2 juillet alors je sais que la
loi n'est pas encore sorti mais on a
voulu faire pour déposer un préavis de
grève à partir du 29 juillet avec sud
pour les soutenir
est-ce qu'on va pas attendre le 15
septembre pour les voir mises à pied
sans salaire
ça c'est très très grave et on manifeste
si aujourd'hui contre le passé militaire
qui pour nous est une loi anti anti
soins parce qu'on peut pas accepter
qu'un refus de soins que des patients
restent à la porte de l'hôpital parce
qu'ils n'ont pas le pass a dit m voilà
donc on est content parce licenciement
comme on dit et on est en compte aussi
le pass anti soignants c'est très grave
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui on est pas
du tout anti-vaccins d'ailleurs notre
fédération sud santé a bien fait une
déclaration là dessus on est pour le
vaccin accessible à 100 % de la
population ce qui aujourd'hui n'est pas
le cas mais on est contre l'obligation
vaccinale et les sanctions qui vont avec
pour des gens qu'à l'époque c'était d
euros et maintenant c'est un danger
public c'est inacceptable et à toulouse
des tensions entre policiers et
manifestants certains d'entre eux
auraient jeté des bouteilles sur les
policiers présents est la police a
aussitôt fait usage de gaz lacrymogènes
pour disperser la foule
ambiance tendue elle donc dans le centre
de la ville rose selon les premières
estimations ils seraient près de 3000
sur place
écoutez les réactions de nos invités
christophe tripodi président de
l'association des commerçants du
quartier méditerranée et président de
l'association force économique uni mais
aussi françois garand ce qui était
médecin qui est médecin spécialiste de
santé publique pour moi par le passé
sanitaire bon permet seulement de paul
et quand on s'est fait vacciner deux
fois après ils ne prouvent pas que l'on
ne puisse pas avoir le coc vide où on
qu'on ne puisse pas le donner aux autres
quand les gens qui ne sont pas l'acier
ne pourront plus aller dans les
établissements donc oui il va y avoir
une baisse une baisse sensible au niveau
des commerçants et la restauration est
moi je pense que déjà ils auront
peut-être pu être plus du moins avoir
une structure intermédiaire c'est-à-dire
que bon peut-être pour les restaurants
laisser la possibilité aux gens déjà
d'aller sur les terrasses peut-être pas
noël ne veux pas leur donner l'accès à
l'intérieur et déjà
sur les terrasses tout ce qui est ouvert
je vois pas pourquoi on devrait pas
donner l'accès surtout qu'après bon je
comprends pas une chose c'est que
pourquoi par exemple l'école bon ben on
n'a pas besoin d'y pas salutaire des
gens qui par exemple et les députés qui
vont à l'assemblée nationale ils n'ont
pas besoin de passe à uniterre donc où
ces deux poids deux mesures donc c'est
ça que je le comprends pas trop mais là
on est dans une situation de crise où on
a un possible regain de la de l'épidémie
avec le variant delta entre les chiffres
qui sont en train de la d'exploser à
nouveau donc
donc là il faut que les décisions soient
prises vite très vite pour limiter des
pertes humaines des b c et d
hospitalisation en réanimation et des
choses très graves
donc il faut un débat qui soit rapide
une prise de décision qui est
nécessairement rapide mais petit pour
autant aucune finalité qui est tout à
fait meubles et qu'il faut garder en
tête qu'ils aient le sauver des vies et
d'empêcher des maladies graves et l'ont
donc je pense qu'aujourd'hui cette
situation est la meilleure possible si
on avait atteint facilement 80 % de taux
de vaccination il aurait pas besoin de
passer ni terre quelque part est
probablement qu'on verrait des chiffres
qui ne sont pas autant en hausse donc là
aujourd'hui on n'est pas encore à 50% de
vacciner totalement en france avec un
peu plus de 47% il me semble et le passé
n'étaient le conseil constitutionnel
rendra sa décision sur ce texte le 5
août
si ce dispositif est déjà en vigueur
dans les lieux culturels depuis le 21
juillet pour de nombreuses personnes à
elles présentent encore des zones
d'ombré on voit cela avec et ma vie pour
le moment vous pouvez toujours faire
comme moi c'est à dire atrassi librement
à une terrasse de café que vous soyez
vacciner ou pas cela dit plus pour très
longtemps puisque si la loi est
promulguée dans les délais annoncés et
bien à partir du 9 août pour accéder à
ce type d'établissement
il vous faudra présenter ce fameux qr
code qui prouve que vous êtes bien
détenteurs d'un pass sanitaire sauf que
pour certaines personnes
cela va s'avérer plus compliquée que
prévu c'est le cas notamment pour les
femmes enceintes jusqu'à récemment
voici ce qu'ils étaient préconisées par
les autorités sanitaires
le conseil d'orientation de la stratégie
vaccinale recommande la vaccination de
toutes les femmes enceintes avec ou sans
comorbidités contre lacko vie 19 et ce à
partir du deuxième trimestre de
grossesse
sauf que depuis les règles ont changé et
les femmes enceintes doivent désormais
se faire vacciner le plus tôt possible
en dehors de ces situations qui
concernent donc potentiellement quelques
centaines de français
il n'y a aucune contre indication aux
vaccins arn messagers ni la grossesse
premier semestre ni la grossesse dernier
trimestre alors on ne va pas revenir sur
les raisons de ce revirement
ce qu'il faut regarder ici c'est la date
à laquelle par le ministre de la santé
le 20 juillet pour un pass sanitaire qui
doit rentrer en vigueur le 9 août en
clair le gouvernement a laissé moins de
trois semaines aux femmes enceintes dans
leur premier trimestre pour se faire
vacciner et obtenir leurs passes
sanitaires et c'est bien ce que
déplorent les principales concernées
que vais-je faire pendant mes vacances
avec mon conjoint et ma soeur qui
m'accompagne et qui eux sont vaccinés
les regarder manger au restaurant et
attendre sur la plage avec un sandwich
je suis déjà nous et eux et je vais me
retrouver à faire la queue toutes les 48
heures environ
parfois sous le soleil en plein
quatrième vague avec des personnes
potentiellement infectées et un risque
accru de devenir cas contacts et ou
infectés peut-on m'expliquer comment une
femme enceinte qui peut potentiellement
se faire vacciner maintenant peut avoir
sont pas sanitaires pour les vacances
c'est techniquement impossible
nous sommes les oubliés de l'été
d'autant que malgré ce que dit olivier
ferrand certains professionnels de santé
déconseille toujours au refusent
carrément de vacciner les femmes
enceintes de moins de trois mois des
femmes enceintes qui devront donc passer
un test pcr pour se
andres alors rendez-vous d'obstétrique
puisque la loi prévoit que le pass
sanitaire est obligatoire dans les
établissements de santé en cas de soins
programmés
autant dire que cela va compliquer le
suivi de leur grossesse
outre les femmes enceintes les
collégiens de moins de 12 ans se trouve
également dans une zone grise
ils n'ont pas accès à la vaccination et
pourtant ils devront quand même passé au
cours à distance si l'on un cas dans
leur classe et vu qu'en 6ème la majorité
des élèves à moins de 12 ans on peut
s'attendre à de nombreuses fermetures de
classes ce qui pénalisera aussi les
élèves qui eux ont bien été vaccinées il
ya aussi la question de la vaccination
des expatriés au ru e
le problème des vaccinés avant le 3 mai
date avant laquelle le qr code
n'existait pas et qu'il faut récupérer
auprès de la personne qui a réalisé
l'injection bref tout un tas de
situations dans lesquelles les français
sont toujours dans l'expectative et le
port du masque fait son retour dans les
zones où la situation sanitaire est
critique c'est le cas de l'ariège pour
cette mesure est imposée dans certaines
communes
dans ce même département la ville de
lavelanet anticipé ferme ses urgences
pour libérer des soignants décisions
déjà prises plusieurs fois mais qui ne
fait toujours pas l'unanimité
reportage sur place hervé grand champ et
walid bennani un panneau d'urgence en
français en anglais pour alerter d'une
énième fermeture en cas d'urgence les
habitants et touristes présents à
lavelanet devront se rendre à une
trentaine de kilomètres au centre
hospitalier de saint jean de verges ou
encore choisir la commune de foix pour
tenter de se faire soigner
on m'écoute et c'est un service de moins
à lavelanet surtout lorsqu'on a des
enfants
ça peut être embêtant
même pour les personnes âgées c'est un
service de moins c'est très embêtant
vous savez 81,6 à être visionné conduit
de fait les quelques trente ou quarante
kilomètres pour aller à l'hôpital si
c'est pas bien une fois il m'a fallu me
rendre juste pour pour un diagnostic
diabétiques
or alors il a fallu commander le stack 6
était injuste pour aller à foix quoi
elle m'a pris cinq minutes pour me dire
à arrêter l'insuline que tout va bien
pour le moment
voilà c'est idiot on aurait un truc ici
roland quoi locaux vides 19 le variant
delta préoccupe tous les indicateurs
sont en hausse dans l'ariège taux
d'incidence taux de positivité personnes
hospitalisées pour pourvoir en médecins
les hôpitaux du département les urgences
de lavelanet ont été sacrifiés au profit
d'un s'est agi d'une commune voisine
cette décision fait suite à
l'aggravation rapide de la situation
sanitaire dans le département de
l'ariège et permet un renforcement
personnel soignant visant à adapter le
capacitaire qu'ovide du centre
hospitalier intercommunal des vallées de
l'ariège durant cette période estivale
les syndicats de leur côté pointent du
doigt des manques de moyens récurrents
depuis des mois financiers et humains
une désertification médicale croissante
qui a obligé à faire des choix
au sein du département c'est un reflet
du manque d'effectifs
en réalité vous avez des médecins
urgentistes sur fois qu'ils ont qui sont
en arrêt maladie
il ya des départs qui sont annoncés pour
le mois de septembre est donc la
direction a besoin de simplement de
récupérer du personnel pour pouvoir
faire tourner son service ensuite met à
mal les autres services de
l'établissement puisque vous avez quand
même un service de médecine un service
de soins de suite de réadaptation qui se
retrouvent sans urgence sur place donc
s'il ya un cas grave on est obligé
d'appeler le 15
ce qui n'est pas normal de recel
l'hôpital pour le maire de lavelanet le
parti pris est inacceptable et les
responsabilités de cette fermeture sont
à chercher du côté de l' agence
régionale de santé d'occitanie je crois
que la rs doit absolument trouver les
moyens pour que à ce niveau là et à bien
d'autres niveaux d'ailleurs mais nous
puissions assurer la sécurité de nos
compatriotes
où que nous soyons et sur tous les
territoires nous sommes un territoire
rural et de montagne et je crois que
dans ces conditions la responsabilité
doit être partagée
les urgences c'est plus de six mille
interventions chaque année donc je pense
que c'est un territoire qui a besoin de
ce genre de service
les urgences de lavelanet sont censé
rouvrir le 15 août mais sans garantie la
direction de l'hôpital a déjà prévenu la
réouverture dépendra de l'amélioration
de la situation sanitaire en outre-mer
la situation est jugée dramatique par le
gouvernement de puiser leur retour du
confinement pour trois semaines en
martinique et quinze jours à la réunion
et la guadeloupe est placée sous
couvre-feu trois patients martiniquais
ont été transférés vers paris
aujourd'hui
écoutez le témoignage de patrick
allemand colonel est médecin à la
réunion et se dit satisfait des
nouvelles mesures instaurées on connaît
depuis trois semaines une augmentation
significative du nombre de cas positifs
à la réunion et justement l'arrivée de
ces deux ce confinement devrait
permettre de limiter l'extension de
cette épidémie à la réunion concernant
l'apport éventuel des structures
militaires
c'est possible mais dans l'état actuel
de notre capacité sanitaires à la
réunion s'est pas encore nécessaire
si on se base uniquement sur les
chiffres c'est vrai que le taux de
vaccination de la population à la
réunion est légèrement en deçà de celle
qui existe actuellement sur le continent
néanmoins on note depuis quelques depuis
quinze jours depuis les propos du
président de la république une
augmentation significative des personnes
qui veulent se faire vacciner et je
pense que la sortie du texte le 9 août
devrait donner encore un nouveau élan à
aux personnes qui aujourd'hui se disent
on le fera mais si la loi nous y oblige
donc je pense que pour l'instant on
vaccine mieux-mieux théâtre sonede et je
pense qu'après le 9 août
il est très probable que nous allons
nous ayons une augmentation
significative du taux de vaccinés à la
réunion
ailleurs dans le monde le coït 19 et le
variant delta continue de frapper c'est
le cas dans de nombreux pays asiatiques
la thaïlande le vietnam le japon mais
également la chine le point de départ de
la première vague de coronavirus est là
bas on a relevé au moins 328 nouveaux
cas dans 14 provinces au cours du mois
écoulé le point avec quentin voeckler la
nuit a beau être tombé sur tongling les
habitants d'un quartier de la ville
continue de faire la queue pour se faire
dépister contre le coc vite 19 dans
cette mégalopole de 31 millions
d'habitants
les autorités sont en alerte face à la
découverte de nouveaux cas de
coronavirus plus de 200 cas d'infection
ont été détectés en chine depuis la
reprise épidémique le 20 juillet lorsque
neuf employés de l'aéroport de nice
chine sont testés positifs depuis plus
de neuf millions de personnes sont
appelées à se faire tester dans la
région où la souche du virus qui se
propage et principalement le variant
delta avec des caractéristiques de
propagation rapide des deux longs délais
pour devenir négatif ce qui pose le plus
grand défi au travail de prévention et
de contrôle des épidémies au 30 juillet
un total de 1 milliard 637 millions
trois cent quatre-vingt quinze mille
doses avaient été administrées dans tout
le pays
nous devons poursuivre nos efforts pour
nous organiser minutieusement et
accélérer le programme de vaccination
les autorités ont ordonné la fermeture
des attractions touristiques du culturel
même scénario dans d'autres régions
chinoises dont pékin où 41 mille
personnes sont confinés depuis jeudi
après la découverte de deux malades
les premiers depuis six mois de nouveaux
foyers épidémiques également en
australie qui inquiète sur place en on
prend de nouvelles restrictions de
confinement aujourd'hui à brisbane pour
trois jours à la troisième plus grande
ville d'australie a recensé sept cas
positifs ce qui est peu pour le moment
mais il s'agit pour les autorités de
limites
et la propagation du variant delta très
contagieux une centaine de cas a été
identifié à sydney qui entame sa
cinquième semaine de confinement écoutez
le ministre de la santé de la nouvelle
galles du sud
je peux dire que le variant data et plus
détecté chez les plus jeunes
il circule définitivement chez les plus
jeunes je tiens à souligner que sur les
deux cent dix cas détectés localement
les deux tiers les deux tiers 138 cas
étaient des personnes de moins de 40 ans
en moyenne dans cinq des six régions de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé les
infections par locaux vides 19 ont
augmenté de 80% soit quasiment doublé en
l'espace de ces quatre dernières
semaines et en afrique les morts ont
augmenté de 80 % sur la même période
selon l'instance le continent bénéficie
du système kovacs d'envoi solidaire de
vaccins 4 millions de doses envoyées la
semaine dernière mais ce ne sera pas
suffisant pour atteindre l'objectif d'au
moins 30 millions d'africains vacciner
écoutez le directeur général de l oms
qui décrit la situation
toutes les régions sont à risque mais
aucune ne l'est plus que l'afrique
sur la base des tendances actuelles près
de 70% des pays africains n'atteindrons
pas l'objectif de vaccination de 10%
d'ici la fin septembre environ 3,5
millions à 4 millions de doses sont
administrés chaque semaine sur le
continent
mais pour atteindre l'objectif de
septembre ce chiffre doit passer à 21
millions de doses au minimum chaque
semaine de nombreux pays africains se
sont bien préparés à déployer les
vaccins mais les vaccins ne sont pas
arrivées boîte de 26 ans avenante
on en vient à ces tensions entre israël
et l'iran après la taxe d'un pétrolier
jeudi au large de man et la mort de deux
membres d'équipage israël accusé l'iran
d'être à l'origine de cet incident a le
pétrolier en question et le maire soeur
street opéré par la société zodiac
maritime qui appartient un militaire
israélien selon l'armée américaine
il s'agirait d'une attaque de drones les
deux membres de l'équipage seraient des
ressortissants roumains et britannique
ces dernières années il ya eu plusieurs
attaques du genre au large
dauman écoutez l'analyse de younes belle
fait là les consultants en relations
internationales et spécialiste du monde
arabe
la guerre entre israël et l'iran elle a
commencé depuis un bouton y habituer
toujours des des attaques réciproques
soient sous forme d' attaque directe
l'utilisation side et des drones des
cyber attaques à travers l'outil
électronique le comportement
expansionniste et la stratégie iranienne
dans dans la région dérange énormément
les autres pays soit israël ou bien même
les alliés du des pays du golfe et donc
certainement c'est ce qui a même poussé
à avoir une certaine alliance implicite
entre israël et les pays du golfe
concernant le sujet le sujet et rania
c'est une guerre entre vraiment des
extrémistes iranien ou au pouvoir dans
leur stratégie est extrêmement clair et
ils ont également un acharnement aussi
contre les pays du golfe est contre et
contre israël face à une autre partie
qui est qui et les pays du golfe et
israël qui se sont en quelque sorte
laissé par les états unis parce que la
nouvelle administration américain de
dubaï densia avec une conception et une
approche très différente par rapport à
celle du 30 qui était basé sur les
sanctions le pouvoir iranien cherche en
quelque sorte à exporter cette crise
interne à travers des projets
expansionnistes contre eux contre le
israël 30e anniversaire aujourd'hui j'ai
traité new start sur le d
moment du clair entre les états unis et
la russie retour sur l'historique et
l'enjeu les enjeux de cet accord en
images regarder
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et c'est la fin de ce journal merci à
vous de l'avoir suivi on va se retrouver
dans une trentaine de minutes rester
avec mon sur rt france
[Musique]
la france oubliée c'est une rencontre
avec ces citoyens qui ne se résignent
pas à la fatalité
on est comme tout le monde je réponds en
appartement on est énervé donnait le
sentiment qu'il faut à chaque fois se
battre ils vivent parfois au bord des
routes nationales pas forcément loin de
paris mais toujours loin de ceux qui les
dirigent
moi je voudrais pas qu'on ait passé un
tour de tracteur avec nous pour en
campagne il faut savoir si j'aime bien
différente
ils ont le sentiment d'être des français
de seconde zone comme s'ils étaient
invisibles ma forêt td quoi un peu plus
aujourd'hui la france oubliée c'est
montrer ce qu'on ne voit jamais
[Musique]